(energetic music)
- First came the grasses.
They came in thick.
Then smaller shrubs.
With them, the insects returned.
Then the trees, and with the trees,
the monkeys and elephants.
Here at Sai Sanctuary, we
have over 300 acres of forest
that we have replanted
and brought back to life.
My full name is Pamela Gale Malhotra,
and I'm co-founder, with my
husband, of Sai Sanctuary Trust.
It had always been our dream
to have a private forest
sanctuary for wildlife,
where they would be protected.
When we first came here,
most of the lands that were sold to us,
were abandoned lands.
Abandoned rice fields, coffee,
and cardamom fields as well.
A lot of deforestation had taken place.
And that took a lot,
a lot of care and energy
and time and years to bring it back.
- She'd really done well this year.
- Yeah, they seem really well.
People thought we were quite
crazy, but that's okay.
A lot of people have thought
people that have done some
amazing things were crazy.
(playful music)
(camera clicks)
Here in the sanctuary, it
is a biodiversity hotspot.
I remember walking through the forest,
you wouldn't hear anything but
the sound of your own feet.
Now, the place is alive with sound.
(birds cawing and chirping)
One of our main sound
makers are the cicadas.
They have a tremendous
decibel range (laughs).
Here they start again.
(cicadas buzzing)
We keep striving to do more and more,
but the initial goal has
been more than achieved.
My hope for the next 10
years for this forest
is that it will continue to
be protected and expanded.
We both feel a tremendous amount of joy
when we walk through the sanctuary.
I've never felt this kind of joy
in anything else that
I've done in my life.